the week two power rankings are out i
post a new set every tuesday
and yeah there's been a little bit of a
shake up we're starting to see who's
good and who's not so good and
down go the 49ers let's start there
chris with the 49ers dropping
from number two down to number six
should i have made them go farther down
on the board than just four spots i
don't think so not yet i i'm okay with
what you did there i i understand that i
think what i look at is just this they
were
this close away
to kind of like blowing that game open
early on so that's where i would go okay
that to me warrants enough of a
i'm not going to drop them that low and
jimmy garoppolo did not play his best
football we knew they were banged up
going into the game a little bit too but
hey when you have a a punt blocked back
in your own area and you give you know
kyla murray and company a short field
and you don't make it on a fourth and
goal you know from a foot and a half out
it's the nfl and you're all of a sudden
you're going to be in a football game i
don't care who you're playing so uh i i
get it i think that was fair
and if you're not hitting your running
backs and your receivers in stride in
that carefully designed kyle shanahan
offense you're not going to pop the big
plays like the one they did for their
first touchdown that raheem mostly
touchdown was a thing of beauty yeah
because it was on the money hit on on
the money in stride isaiah simmons you
know first guy i feel bad for the guy
first game in an nfl uniform he stepped
the wrong way and there goes raheem
mostert and we didn't see enough of that
from jimmy garoppolo and company but
they still have the capacity to do it
they should win the next few games and
start to build some momentum but they're
going to be in a very tough division oh
and they have to play the cardinals
again after the cardinals beat them the
seahawks in the nfc west they moved up
four spots that accounts for most of the
disruption in the top five i had them at
number eight but after what they did to
the
to the falcons and the way russell
wilson looked and the the promise of
seeing that on a regular basis
that caused me to move them past the
49ers who lost but also past the saints
who won because as you pointed out
there's cause for concern with the
saints even though they got the victory
so i i said to hell with it i'm putting
the seahawks ahead of the scene i i
don't know if i would have done that but
i i can i certainly can understand why i
mean you're right i there there is
things to be concerned about you know
the saints uh they they did play a team
that we're all looking at going oh
they're supposed to be a pretty damn
good team this year but the way seattle
played i think you kind of hit it
so that's why it's hard to argue russell
wilson looks so awesome and then
jamal adams looked so awesome on the
defensive side of the ball you just went
whoa
it's kind of changed if they're gonna
play this style and they seemed and i
haven't watched that defensive side of
the film i watched seattle on offense i
haven't watched seattle on defense it
seemed like they might have done a
little bit more on the defensive side of
the ball than usual schematically
because of jamal adams that excites me
and yeah i got no problem with that like
i said i don't know if i would have had
him jump to saints yet but i understand
that completely and uh russell looks so
good
it's okay i'll let it slide and let me
let me say this about russell wilson and
jamal adams when i spoke to russell
after the game and look we we know how
russell is russell's going to always say
good things about his teammates as he
should he was keeping praise on everyone
but when i asked him specifically about
jamal adams he stopped and he started
rattling off with an exclamation point
after every word every positive thing
you could say about a player hall of
fame championship caliber leadership
intensity emotion it was different it
was delivered differently than anything
else he said so they know they got
something special in jamal adams and
that helps put the both sides of the
ball together and puts them in position
where they can be really good and they
take on the number three patriots on
sunday night football and that should be
a great game and we got to pick a winner
in that one chris oh you know we're
doing our pix podcast i got no i have no
clue i just feel that no matter what i
do i'm going to be wrong i have no clue
who's gonna win that game all right uh
the cardinals also in the nfc west i
moved them from 20 up to number 12. hey
hey they did look here's the thing and
and somebody somebody wrote in the
document that we used to communicate
confirmation bias for a team that got
some off season hype hey look i would
have put them higher than number 20 if i
bought the hype the reality is they went
into santa clara and kicked the crap out
of the 49ers they beat them they out 49
or the 49ers they won they they wore
them down they won the game they had the
far better quarterback and i'm not going
to say they're the better team right now
but man they they pulled it off and they
showed me something and they showed me
they belong in the top 12 chris yeah
well i think the thing that jumps out to
me and i know you're probably going to
talk about this team next is that you
got four teams in the nfc west all in
the top 13 teams in football which is
kind of
amazing
i hear you there can i see the rest of
those power rankings can we throw that
back up on the screen again uh like i
think you're in the right range for the
cardinals i don't think i would have put
them in front of the rams
but other than that
i got no issue with it either okay i do
we don't know what the cowboys are i
want i mean i think the cowboys are a
better football team than the cardinals
okay i'll say this week one yeah i
probably would have put the cardinals at
15. i probably still would have got
another week with rams cowboys eagles
and just gone with that because i'm not
quite sure
about the cardinals yet but there are
other questions there about the other
teams too but it's not egregious i i
hear you i mean that was a big win and
they got some special difference-making
type players on their team
here's here's why
i moved the rams up 10 spots because
even now when i look at it's like what
the hell was i thinking yeah because
they easily could have lost the game
they easily could have lost the game i
disagreed with the michael gallup
offensive pass interference call in part
because i wanted the cowboys win because
i picked them to win i mean that's the
thing who are you rooting for in these
games the team that you pick to win
because you want to be right i'm not
going to root for the team i i mean we
we develop a natural rooting interest in
all 256 regular season games because we
pick a winner for every game yeah so
shocker
we want to be right so we root to be
right and i wanted the cowboys to win
because i thought they would the reason
i put the rams up where they were that
was an admission by me that i was wrong
to have them as low as i yeah i misread
right broom going in that with all the
changes without todd gurley without wade
phillips that without brandon cooks that
this was going to be a middle to bottom
of the pack team and by holding off the
cowboys one of the better teams in the
conference supposedly yeah that made me
admit i was wrong and i that that that
kind of a jump
now for the cardinals the eight point
jump is my regret that i didn't have him
higher in the first place for the rams
the 10-point jump is they should have
been up in that range in the first yeah
well i remember back in the when you
first let out the the rankings i think
that was probably my biggest question
right was just going i think you're just
disrespecting the rams a little bit and
not to sit here to tell you like i'm
right or anything like that but yeah i
think when you when you see them on the
field and then you remember like damn
mcveigh's a good coach too i got to
remember that he's he's got an advantage
on a lot of coaches and the way he
called that game i mean mcveigh was the
number one reason they won that game the
pace of the offense all the
what i would call bull crap completions
were just their mcveigh you could put a
you could put johnny from seventh grade
out there and he would have completed
most of those passes there was nothing
there it was just sean mcveigh's
specials but when you talk about cooper
cup and you see the running backs you're
pretty good and then you go oh robert
woods is real good and then they got a
pretty good two-headed monster at tight
end you know and yeah the offensive
line's not great but you can see mcveigh
can make up for some of the lack of like
great talent there and then you say the
defense has difference makers and i
think that's where
you know
yeah it's not like the best most
complete football team but between good
coaching
battle tested
and some real big time play makers who
can sway the game like and aaron donald
and jalen ray ramsey woods and all those
guys yeah they're going to be a pain in
the butt and it's why i picked them to
go to the playoffs we'll see how it
works out though as we go forward the
packers beat the vikings and it caused
the packers to jump from 14 to number
nine another semi-admission i was wrong
to have the packers where i had them hey
i can own it i can admit it we don't
know nobody knows what the hell is going
to happen until it happens yeah that's
right the vikings i dropped from 13 to
number 22 because that's where they
deserve to be based upon what we saw on
sunday the last time they gave up that
many points now actually they never gave
up 43 in a season opener they gave up 42
in 1984. that was the
failed les steckel experiment the one
and done where they went three and 13.
he was a drill sergeant in training camp
it blew up in his face the team was
horrible i don't know if they're quite
gonna go there
but
i don't see this team winning more games
and it loses based on what we saw on on
uh sunday chris so yeah 22 is where the
vikings are and they're gonna stay there
until they earn their way out of it
right
defense i don't think's elite
offense is
just okay and too predicated on like oh
we gotta run the ball to open everything
up and i don't it's not like they're the
tennessee titans offensive line or
derrick henry that way so i don't know i
do i got major questions about the
vikings and i got no issue with you
having them right there i think that's
realistically where they are in that
range anywhere from you know 17 to 22 or
23.
now
the packers
man yeah the packers look better than i
even expect them to look and if they're
gonna have that aggressive nature on the
defensive side i mean on the offensive
side of the ball and attack a little bit
more this year through the air with more
aggressive passes
they might be on to something not to say
their team's perfect but i do like the
way it looked and rogers looked really
really good i mean i was impressed with
the way he looked even physically you
know last year i thought mike i thought
rogers got it too much into the like
he talked about it yoga staying loose
and limber
tom does this brady does this and i i i
thought there was an issue last year i
wanted to go hey you're not tom brady
you know that's not your game you need
to be able to hop around and run and
explode and be really quick and
explosive that way and you know there
was points last year where i swear i
would watch games and i would go he
can't fill his pants out right now you
know his pants are droopy on his butt
and you know i look at that region of
any football player
first thing i saw in the game on sunday
it was i said rogers looks better in his
uniform he looks like he had a little
more muscle he looked like he had a
little more pop on his arm and in his
legs and when you have that and you're
aaron rodgers you say watch out
maybe he just got pants that fit him
better maybe he did but it didn't look
like it by just the way his arms two
quarterbacks that i looked like that i
thought looked a little more buff
desean watson on thursday night i
thought he looked a little bit more like
he put some armor on because he knows he
plays a little bit of a reckless style
and i think rogers got back to where
roger should be
you know he his movement's still a big
part he can't be like tom tom
just wants to slide and be smooth around
the pocket rogers you see it's
spin flip run run well shoo man it's
just a different kind of game and he
can't make his body to be like tom brady
because that's not what he does
all right uh the texans oh this is i
gotta watch here for you this is this
one i don't get we're gonna challenge
you on this one all right
there's the bottom half the texans there
at number 17 unchanged from last week
even though they lost at kansas city in
the first game of the season last
thursday night the browns though
sent to the bottom of the stack
after losing to the ravens 38 to 6 they
dropped from 18 down to number 32.
what's your what what's your problem
with me leaving the texans where they
were after losing to the chiefs but but
pulling the plug on the browns after
losing to the ravens well this is like
something that me and pete did a little
little lightest lightest were texting
about last night you know because we
knew we were going to talk about this
and we saw your power rankings so yeah
we want to pick them apart but i just
want to know explain this to me michael
florio
okay this is texans simple stay at 17 to
the number one team in football browns
lose to the second best team in football
but you dropped them 14 spots defend
yourself
well here's the thing the texans right i
i
they they drew
a a really short straw right out of the
gates the first game of the season they
got to go into a stadium with 16 000
people there on a weekend when only the
jaguars had anyone present by way of
fans in all the other games and i
thought the texans did as well as they
could under the circumstances of going
in to play the best team in the nfl
the brown
you know for all the reasons we
discussed earlier in the show whether
it's the ill-advised design of the fake
punt whether it's the refusal to stick
with what's working with nick chubb and
kareem hunt whether it's the odell
beckham jr dysfunction i mean once you
get down into the range of dysfunctional
teams i started looking at all the other
teams and and here's the thing there was
no one else to put at 32. put the bottom
half back up please that's why i ended
up picking the browns because i compared
the browns of the panthers hey the
panthers the panthers did themselves
proud against the raiders they shouldn't
be number 32. the giants game against
the steelers a hell of a lot closer than
it should have been then the final score
would suggest they don't deserve to be
32 the bengals could have won the game
or at least forced overtime but for a
kicker missing a field goal they don't
deserve to be number 32. there was no
one else that deserved to be number 32.
the browns deserved it because of the
way they lost the way they performed and
the way it's heading this is the warning
sign cleveland you're right back where
you were a couple of years ago if you
don't fix this now and the easiest way
to fix it is trade odo beckham jr yeah
yeah i i listen i i hear you and i think
everything you said was was right it was
it was a bad look it was a very bad look
and that was like we talked about
there's no excuse
yeah i don't know if i would have put
him at 32 i don't know if i would have
uh i probably would have put him
somewhere in that
i probably would have still kept the
panthers at 32. i think i probably would
have
even though it was a good effort and
they played well
i just think just from what i i still i
guess the talent on the roster with the
browns
i still think would verify for me one
more week to maybe have them at least 27
or 28 but the points you make are real
who's who's 32 then who was the one team
you would put at 32 right now pick a
team and you tell me and defend why you
would make them the worst team in the
nfl yeah i mean i i think you could sit
there and i like i said i think you
could have the panthers at 32. i got no
issue that or even the new york giants
if you wanted to go that way you know
but it is tough but yes i mean the
panthers
it was fun to watch and everything like
that i don't know how good the raiders
are either i mean the raiders defense is
it's stinky so
i guess with those young parts and just
hey it is week one
and you talk about hey the the browns
got the the short straw by dealing with
the ravens the panthers got the right
team to kind of give us a somewhat of a
good look in their week one
and you don't know what to expect from
them because we haven't seen what they
want to do or how they want to attack so
they had that advantage but um yeah i
probably would have had one of those
teams down towards the bottom over
cleveland and give them a respect one
more week but i get what you're saying i
hear you i'm drooling on myself sorry
let's see what happens on thursday night
though the browns host the bengals what
have they learned from what happened on
sunday and you know coming off of that
kind of a loss do you want to get back
on the horse that quickly or do you want
to have the benefit of a full week uh i
think you'd want to have the benefit of
a full week especially with the new
coaching staff still and all that to
just have a little more time to digest
the game
hey
you know and instead of a tuesday now
where they're like we got to get the
game plan ready guys get in here we
gotta have practice we gotta have
meetings everything like that tuesday
would be the day if it was a normal week
where the coaches the organization could
all sit down and go wait where did we
mess up with our plan of attack last
week what are we really going to do with
our team here and i think it lets you
yeah you know dive into some of the
issues with your team a little bit more
right now you have no time for that you
just got to like kind of correct on the
fly we're playing a team let's go but
hopefully they can catch up with the
long weekend after the thursday game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports